what real danger looks like that's the
focus of tonight's angle
he's got early stage of dementia he
repeats the same stories over and over
again this is what makes donald trump a
dangerous person i mean he he has a bent
towards authoritarianism
first public discussion of using the
25th amendment to remove donald trump
from power was on this program one month
into the trump presidency this president
is a danger to us and the world
of course to those clowns a dangerous us
president is one who puts america's
interests first who stalwartly defends
american sovereignty and prosperity
even when our allies by the way grouse
and complain you're supposed to stand
for america but they don't like that
because to them an authoritarian is a
republican who calls out the press and
refuses to be swallowed by the swamp
the fact is trump wasn't a threat to
america's standing in the world or to
our economy
he was a threat to the old order
and now 10 months into the bide
administration america sees what real
danger looks like
it looks like a bumbling fool who
squints and stumbles his way through
remarks repeating old stories from his
childhood
when biden speaks i find myself wincing
just
talking about
the long over almost 200 years from a
relationship
with mexico
and we were talking about i was
explaining why roosevelt and lincoln
were
their portraits were up on the wall
yeah
it's funny until you think about the
ramifications for america now everybody
knows what's going on here a new
politico morning consult poll shows that
48 of voters say that biden is mentally
unfit to be president that's up 13
points from a year ago
among independents it's far worse the
biden the margin there is 23 points for
biden
now liberals aren't going to believe me
but i actually take no glee in biden's
decline
because we need a president our kids
need a president our future generations
need a president whose physical and
intellectual capacity
is never in serious doubt
anything less than that puts us all in
peril
now
because if joe biden is too weak or too
out of it to take on the squad look we
know he's obviously
a lost cause against presidents putin or
she if he's too diminished to speak off
the cuff when i don't know he has the
milwaukee bucks coming to visit the
white house
you can only imagine
how he sounded during monday's two-hour
call with his chinese counterpart
foreign leaders our adversaries our
allies alike they all see that biden's
gross deficiencies are really their
golden opportunities
they're ruthlessly pursuing their own
geopolitical agendas and they know that
joe biden's presidency created a giant
vacuum for them to exploit
look putin's on a roll first the
nordstrom 2 pipeline and next it might
be taking back ukraine
i still remember when democrats cared
about what happened to ukraine not so
much now and as for beijing biden's
presidency isn't just a dream come true
after four years of trump's tough trade
posture and generally roaring economy
china is thrilled to see biden
floundering
now if china's going to take taiwan it's
hard to see why they wouldn't move while
biden's in office
i mean
no one in the biden orbit even
understands this they don't understand
china they don't understand china's true
intentions
an america weakened economically led by
a present president who's weakened
mentally
sets up china perfectly for the next
three years
now think about this the ccp
is so emboldened now
that a few months before the world comes
for the olympics to beijing they feel
totally comfortable making their own
global athletic stars disappear
a chinese tennis star made sexual
harassment allegations against a party
leader
and hasn't been seen since
we're going to have more on that little
mystery later on in the show
now one thing we do know however is that
biden's vice president
i mean she is completely incapable of
stepping in to take over as
commander-in-chief should biden be
incapacitated
she has problems delivering simple
remarks
because
i'm sorry she knows nothing except how
to play the race card to get ahead
the generations of women
black women who fought and sacrificed so
much
including the black women who are often
too often overlooked and what a
testament it is
to joe's character
that he had the audacity to select a
woman as his vice president
it's always a diversity thing how about
merit how about that for a change well
it turns out that selecting a vp based
solely on diversity criteria not
objective merit is not only stupid
it's really dangerous
there is literally no situation no
problem that the white house can turn
over to her to handle in the face of the
president
like i mean she was supposed to handle
the border remember that
well america's border is now overrun
with drugs illegals and sex traffickers
nice job kamala
now the biden people obviously never
intended to enforce our border laws
which is why they put her in charge of
it
it's not going to be overnight we can't
just flip a switch and make it better
the reality is that we inherit a system
an immigration system that was deeply
broken
and it's requiring us to actually put it
back together in terms of creating a
fair
process that is effective and efficient
okay she said and she inherited a system
that was broken no she inherited a
sealed border by trump she's a bad liar
no wonder the woman's at 28
approval no one likes her including the
president's top advisors
increasingly they just give her
meaningless tasks
so you don't feel misused or underused
no i don't i am very very excited about
the work
that we have accomplished
yeah those girl scout pinning ceremonies
are a lot of fun george now if her goal
was to just pump up our enemies and
demoralize our own people then she
should be excited
no wonder democrats are already worrying
about who can run in 2024 can you
believe that they're already worrying
about that by 2021
they already know that kamala would
crash and burn it's all a mess
we currently have a rudderless america
run by a hapless president
and as a result the whole world is going
to pay
but the strength of this country is not
in our government
it's in our people
we survive jimmy carter we survive
herbert hoover and we'll survive this
and when republicans do
regain control of the house and the
senate they're going to need to be ready
on day one no more fussing around no
long recesses we need real oversight
hearings run by the best staff the most
talented lawyers out there
trillions of dollars are going to be
pouring into bogus efforts that look
nothing like the bridges and tunnels
that we all been hearing about and it's
going to be up to the gop to call out
every aspect of this waste fraud and
abuse track it really track it
and then make it clear to our enemies
your little honeymoon under joe biden
is over
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else